[Music]
thank you so much for being here we're
thrilled to have you today obviously a
lot of excitement here let's just take a
quick poll how many of you use uber
that's like a hundred percent thank you
use uber used uber this week that's like
80 90 so this feels like what our
professors are talking about when they
are teaching us about product market fit
now how many of you have used uber pool
Wow pretty good 75 yeah it's good so we
have so much to talk about today I would
love to start you know with Iran but
then eventually move on to i AC Alan and
Co Expedia uber sounds great great so
starting from the beginning your family
seven with seventy five hundred miles
away from here in the Bay Area in Iran
and that's where you grew up they were
running a hugely successful conglomerate
yes in 1978 you ended up having to flee
eventually seeking asylum here in the
United States when you got here you
didn't speak fluent English sometimes
you introduce yourself as Darren Kay
instead of Derrick coaster shahe those
were dark days yes how did how did the
challenge of assimilation shape you as a
leader so I think first of all I was a I
was a kid I was nine years old and and I
think that children as you know are much
more flexible and they can assimilate
much more easily into any situation
different situations but I was also I
was also the youngest brother and I was
one of the younger cousins in the family
so I was very very low on the totem pole
and I had to assimilate even before I
came to the States whatever was going on
I had no no say in the matter
and coming to the States for us what we
had was we always had family and that
was a constant and and is a constant for
me in that really I I certainly was
thrown into noon
but I was I always had the protection a
family to come home to we were very
lucky to have a very strong education in
Iran and we continue to have a strong
education in the US I learned a lesson
that if you don't understand what
someone is saying the answer is no not
yes because whenever it's an Iranian
thing you always want to say yes so I'd
have no idea what's almost saying yes
yes and then I'd be like playing
football someplace having no idea how to
catch a ball but but you know oui oui
for me the assimilation that really got
us in was through sports and we played
soccer was kind of the game of the world
and not so popular in the US so we were
regarded as soccer gods and my high
school and and that's how we got to know
a lot of other kids and really
assimilate it into the school do you
keep up with sports oh yeah absolutely
I'm uh I'm of course I'm a big
Premiership soccer fan so that's my I
wake up at 5:30 in the morning my wife
says I'm crazy
but she's good with it so it's hard to
know your personal identity you came
here as a child and you found your way
it's also hard to know your professional
identity yeah and you know when you were
at Allen & Company
you met Barry Diller yes and he has a
reputation where some comment that he is
demanding but loyal you identified him
as someone you wanted as a mentor how
did you know that and what advice can
you give us on cultivating mentorship
yeah sure I mean he was uh he was my
first true mentor and and the way that I
met him in Allen company we were I was a
young analyst working on a deal this was
a hostile tender offer that Barry had
launched for Paramount Pictures he was
running QVC
there was a deal for Viacom which was a
big conglomerate is a is a big
conglomerate to buy Paramount Pictures
and Barry was really interested in the
in the combination of Commerce and
entertainment and when that when
Paramount became in play he went after
and I was an analyst on a deal and he's
like this giant Hollywood mogul and and
that this was a really dramatic offer
where we were making bids and then they
make beds etc was a very competitive
public battle for control of this highly
strategic asset at the time and and the
band the thing they remember about Barry
is somehow he found out and you know he
would deal with an SVP who was at a VP
and associate and somehow he found out
that I was running the deal model yeah
that was this and I was on the trading
floor just this nobody and he found out
that I was wearing the deal model and he
comes up to me he's like you're you're
the one running the deal model right
yes mr. Diller and he's like okay I want
you to explain to me exactly how it
works I said what he said right now and
of course when Barry Diller says right
now you say okay so I sat down with him
and he wanted to know everything about
the deal model from the person who had
actually built it and he took the time
and and and I learned as I got to know
Barry that one of the things that he
really believes in is going to the
source that every time you get
information that is filtered you lose
fidelity in the information and this was
a really important deal for him and he
instead of being comfortable with
someone who would present information to
him in a perfectly clean and comfortable
way he wanted to be uncomfortable with
an unknown but knowing that he'd be
closer to the truth and that was how a
relationship started and and he would
like come to me on the deal model
rebidding too much or he bidding too
little he was making the decisions but
he really wanted to go to the source and
and understand kind of the core of the
subject matter we lost that battle and I
still remember his uh he he released a
statement saying we lost they won next
you know and when I read that thing I'm
like I want to be a part of next so with
that he went after he we
went after a bunch of other deals and
masa Nations and when the predecessor
company to IAC was born it was home
shopping netwerk at the time he sold QVC
took control of Home Shopping Network we
closed on a very large deal to buy an
entertainment business Universal
Television and at that point he said
well I want you to work exclusive me
exclusive me exclusively as my deal
person I said I can't do that I've got a
portfolio he said I want I want your
portfolio to be me and I said well then
give me a job and he said let's go so
that's when I jumped onboard with them
and and that the one lesson that I
learned from Alan and company
Herbert Allen was the is was a CEO of
the time he always said that as an
investor he didn't bet on companies he
bet on people you know he's just said
bet on people I make my bet on people
and I think one lesson for me that I
took away was I was an investor I was an
employee right but instead of making a
bet on the job or instead of making a
bet on the company I was making a bet on
a person and I said you know Barry
Diller if this is a person that I want
to work with whatever you want me to do
I'll do it and I followed him and it was
you know it's been a great decision in
my life he eventually sponsored you yes
very much so
and tapped you to be the CEO of Expedia
yeah this is 14 years out of college I
guess so yeah accident desperate well
you proved yourself right yes yes i
Expedia you grew the business from two
to ten billion dollars over 13 years mmm
very impressive at the same time your
competitor Priceline they they were a
distant competitor at the time you
started being CEO yeah and then
eventually actually became the leader in
the online travel agency stays very
painful even I hear you say yes they
grew to four times the size of Expedia
I'm not sure when when us
all right so you had so many successes
yes I'm curious you know what you think
your key wins were and what you would
have done differently so I think I'll
talk about booking.com cents or price as
well without booking group since you
brought up this was a company that we
looked at and an Expedia was one of the
big players in the travel industry that
was growing incredibly quickly and we
were taking on kind of the offline
travel agents and and the traditional
players and what we saw with booking.com
was a player who had very very low
margins and what prevented us from
ultimately competing with them the way
that we should have was that we didn't
want to give up our own fat margins you
know to be frank and it goes to the
whole issue of the innovators dilemma we
saw this business and listen we had
opportunity to buy them just like
Priceline actually bought booking calm
and booking calm became 95% of the
business and they renamed the business
booking calm we had the same opportunity
to buy that company but in looking at
that company our team Connor poopoo did
because it was a less the unit economics
of that model didn't look as good and
instead of looking at that as an asset
our team looked at it as a liability and
for me that's a very important lesson in
that it's it's much easier for a
business to make all the tough decisions
and shape their business based on low
economics and low margins and then
expand an expansion is inevitably faster
if you have a low priced product
especially in the internet world where
you know price is something that is
easily discoverable it's much easier to
go from low margin to expand than be the
high margin player and then slowly bring
your margin down we did bring our margin
down over a long period of time but if I
had to do something quicker I would have
done it I would have taken the pain
upfront I would have done
faster and I think that for us as a
company when we started taking that
margin pain and when we started really
rethinking our business not as a travel
company but as a technology company that
was a turn that Expedia had to go
through to create value for us but it's
absolutely less lesson learned which is
you know low margins are an asset
they're not a liability and and to lose
that cost discipline ultimately is gonna
cost you market share over the long term
when did you realize that and went and
went out how quickly did you adapt that
Expedia you know we realized it actually
pretty quickly and and the issue was
that we had to go from a situation where
transaction was worth call it 25 percent
to 15 percent so we had to essentially
engineer 40 percent of our revenues out
of the model and that was a process that
took us it took us a couple of years to
realize and then we started engineering
it over a period of two or three years
what allowed us to engineer it was
really making the bet on our core
technology platforms and for me one of
the toughest things that I went through
at Expedia was that Expedia was a
holding company number of different
brands within the holding company and
the largest part of the business was
Expedia comm a flagship full-service
online travel agency and I had failed
twice in finding a leader for that
business found a person didn't work out
brought in another person didn't work
out and this was a particularly tough
time for me in the board and I went to
the board and Barry I said well I've got
to bring in another person if I'm over
three I think you should fire me Barry
said you're damn right so I said well
then my third pick is gonna be me I
don't understand what it takes to run
this business I've and the only way I'll
understand is if I run it for a while so
I I was the CEO the corporate parent and
then I was I was the CEO the operational
CEO of expedia comm and I learned more
during those four or five years when I
ran Expedia comm than I ever learned in
my life and I learned what it really
means to operate a company I learned
what it really means for business and
technology to come to come together to
really take risks to really accelerate
the rate of innovation within a company
operationally and once we started
turning expedia.com around the company
overall started turning around and I was
lucky enough then to hand that business
off to the CTO of expedia.com at a time
who's still running that business so
that was the real big turn and and for
me it was a great learning opportunity
and I will I I know I would not be in a
spot had I not made the mistake of not
being able to find the right person to
run Expedia comm moving on from Expedia
my painful loss the booking thank you
well it's a win in the end right two to
ten yes so in August 2017 not too long
ago
the uber board selected you to be their
CEO yes yes and I would presume that
each of you the board and yourself had
requests of each other
reportedly Barry Diller helped you
during this three-week negotiator you
know well it wasn't a negotiation
process it was an interview process
really okay yeah all right well I'm
curious about either way we can talk
about the negotiation or the interview
but I'm most curious about the
negotiation and if you can offer us any
advice on negotiating job offers
although on a much smaller scale well
let me tell you so one of the advantages
that that I had in in approaching this
role was that I had a great job already
and I loved what I was doing at at
Expedia and I really wasn't looking to
jump ship and he was both part of the
interview process and the negotiation
process where you know during the
interview process I was just dead honest
about what I brought to the table and
and what I thought I
needed in order to succeed at the
company and I still remember it was a
that there was the various candidates
and and there were other candidates who
were much better known you know they're
like capital letters candidates they
came in and presented to the board and
and I made a presentation to the board
where I talked about my expectations of
the board and part of expectations for
the board were you know what happens in
the board room stays in the board room
doesn't get tweeted out someplace right
and also that with with the founders of
the company being very much a part of
the company spirit and culture and what
built that company if they really wanted
a new leader of that company they needed
it needed to be very clear who the
leader was and that I expected the board
to be there for me but I needed the
freedom to maneuver appropriately and
make changes that I felt needed to be
made quickly because this was a tough
situation so I was very straight with
the board about those issues and I
remember one of the board members after
the meeting said you know all of it was
great but that that page was really it
was not not such a great it was not that
well-received by the board I said well
if it wasn't that well-received man I'm
glad because this is important to me and
for whatever reason you know maybe they
ignore that page but I I just think that
when when you get into a situation in a
new opportunity or you're or a new
opportunity that that presents itself
you know being transparent about your
own capabilities and and I think you've
got to go first and hopefully then
getting the transparency back from from
the other party that you're talking
about ultimately it's a win-win because
you never want to get yourself in a
position where where you're at the wrong
job you don't have the capabilities etc
and and vice versa
you know it's a loss for both parties so
I've taken this
you know one thing that I've learned
from Barry is is he's just the most
transparent person on earth he just lays
it out there I think you you diane von
fürstenberg was here and you know I fear
she was pretty transparent about a lot
of things it's just it's it's part of
that that core culture that that he
taught me it's something that I took to
that board we had some very frank
discussions about expectations both ways
and it's something that since I've taken
to the company I think in the second
Town Hall that we had as a company I
actually took my board presentation and
I presented at the All Hands I said this
is me this is actually what I talked to
the board about and it's the same deck
and you know this is this is where
you're gonna get with me and then we go
on from there that it is it was a tough
decision
yeah to move to BER from Expedia you had
a clear idea of what you wanted in one
of one of our most sought-after classes
here at the GSB called leadership
perspectives with Joel Peterson and
Charles O'Reilly we often asked visiting
leaders what winning is to them you know
you traded the top job at Expedia but
you were very happy and just doing
tremendous things for this job at uber
which some in the press described as a
lose-lose situation
I obviously wasn't reading that press
ultimately what-what-what is winning to
you how did you think about that um
honestly I wasn't thinking about winning
I'll relate one story which was a funny
story when when I was first reached out
for the for the job I buy some
headhunters I said no way I was happy
where I was and and then I I was having
a drink with a friend of mine actually
the Daniel Hecht the CEO Spotify at a
conference and he asked me he said have
they reached out to you because I told
them I think you'd be perfect for this
role I said yeah but you know I'm I'm
happy I'm I'm I'm doing great Expedia
I'm I'm you know I'm not gonna why would
I ever do that he looks at me he says
Doris is what is life
happiness he stared at me with a
Scandinavian eyes and the a said it's
about doing something great and my wife
was there Syd was there as well and and
she's like come on man let's you should
go for this so between those two that
was kind of the moment that that changed
for me and and listen there are there
are very few times in your life when you
can change the world or you can change
something that's truly important and for
me the advice that I always give folks
that I talked to as far as careers is I
think that people often optimize way too
much for the role or the company etc the
first thing that I was optimize for us
who are you gonna work with and the
people that I met on that board even
though there were questions about the
board they were excellent that the folks
that I taught to on the board and the
second is the second third are can you
go to a place where you personally can
make a difference and can you go to a
place that's making a difference you
know I was in investment banking where I
was making a difference but I didn't
feel like the impact on the world was
quite there and this super opportunity
for me was this is an extraordinary
opportunity to make an impact at a
company that's making an impact of the
world and my attitude was it's not about
winning or losing it's actually about
taking a shot and you know if if I took
a shot and I won then glory come upon me
or whatever it is but even if I took a
shot and I failed and I don't plan to
fail I took that freaking shot and you
know when I'm 30 years from now 40 years
from now I'm gonna have a great great
story to tell my kids and their kids
that to me is the definition of winning
like winning is getting in the game is
is playing the game and for me a big
part of winning is winning as a team
like I don't want to win alone it's so
much more fun to celebrate with
teammates it's so much more fun to
celebrate as a tribe as a family so me
is you know for me winning is I'm
playing in a game
and it's a really important game and
I've got a team around me and if we win
it's gonna be a great story one of the
central tenants you mentioned was going
to a place where you can have impact
yeah
to be sure there was a lot to do at uber
when you came on and in particular ooh
BRR has gone through hell because of
accusations around me - unprofessional
management safety issues yeah
the culture was thought to over index on
this culture of begging forgiveness
versus asking permission how did you
address that specifically and what's
left to do so I think first of all the I
don't know if the company well I kind of
know that that the company wouldn't have
succeeded and been in that position in
the first place without that culture so
I know that it's very easy to criticize
it after the fact etcetera but the fact
is that there are very few companies
that have created the kind of brand and
the kind of service that that team
created you know the world it was
historic it is historic it will be
historic but the one thing that I've
learned is that success imprints much
more forcefully than failure and what
the pattern that you see with companies
is that anytime you have a success of
course it's because of you and
everything that you do in your culture
etc and if there's a failure I was a
it's the market or the market wasn't
right timing wasn't right it's always
someone else so success sometimes and
the kind of success that uber had was so
extraordinary that actually in hindsight
it kind of made sense that the success
was born out of you know aggression and
going for it and not taking no for an
answer and and running through doors and
it worked and it works spectacularly but
but that hid some negatives and some
very significant negatives that were
forming as a result of that culture and
and I think that you know I have an
experience the kind of success that
Hoover experienced early on I don't know
if I would have seen it because because
they're too busy winning and they're too
busy being on the photo spread of a
magazine
talking about how they're changing the
world and how they can do no wrong so
you know I want to be careful about how
we think about this situation where we
wound up was that once the winning
stopped you know the fall was really
really tough and it happened suddenly
and I think the company hadn't built the
the bulwark and the framework to be able
to resist that kind of the wall that
they hit and they needed a change and
and you know I'm here and I can be a
part of that change that said what we
wound up with was a culture that was I
think not diverse enough there was one
way and there was the only the way that
was defined kind of as a uber way the
company had not taken the time to think
about diversity of thought diversity of
origin gender diversity thinking about
under represented minorities and their
position at the company I think that a
company was a little bit too top-down
you know and and it's part of the power
of a founder led company but it can also
be part of the weakness of a founder of
a company and I think these are all
actions that we're taking you know this
is a company we are truly a global
company the connection that we have with
the cities that we operate in we're not
just a digital company the connection
that we have with the cities that we
operate in or physical and are
fundamental when our payment system goes
down we have drivers who don't get paid
and some of them need to get paid in
order to afford dinner that night so the
connection that we have with the cities
with our driver partners with our riders
are so fundamental and so important that
it's incredibly important as we develop
as a company to be as diverse as the
business the riders and the drivers that
we're serving to be diverse in our views
in our international viewpoints etc and
we are working very hard and bringing a
leadership team that values that
diversity and then pushing down the
culture of truly celebrating differences
truly being at one and in service of the
cities in which
we operate but it's a journey it's only
been a year and it's a start but it's
something that I and I think our
leadership team are incredibly
passionate about and the opportunity for
us is you know that I think there's just
dislocation between technology companies
and the rest of the world and it's
coming out in a lot of ways we're not
the only tech company we're some sent a
tip of the sphere the spear here but I
think as a technology company we touch
people in a way that other tech
companies don't it's fundamental I think
we're in touch in the cities in which we
operate so I think we can we as uber
have the opportunity to be that next
generation technology leader both in
terms of culture but actually how we
connect to the cities and and the
constituencies that that we that we work
with and operate around so it's a big
job but I'm psyched for what is what's
one specific example of a seed that
you're sowing right now that that could
actually ultimately look like what
you're describing as an ideal stone well
I think you know we're thinking about
our driver partners we've always called
our driver partners partners but I don't
think we've treated them as such in the
past so now when we are launching our
product the the driver app we actually
go to our driver partners we do the
research with them we for the first time
really we got driver partner beta
testers and go out there and we actually
build not what we think they should have
but actually what they're telling us
they should have as well so that's it's
just a very different way of building
product than that we've had in the past
one of the areas where we're thinking
about for our driver partners or
insurance right it's what if they get
into accident paternity material et
cetera and we have partnered with a with
AXA in Europe to actually provide these
kinds of insurance coverages for our
driver partners and it's something
that's been incredibly well received so
that you know that might not have been a
direction that old uber would have gone
through but I think that a more mature
or uber an uber that understands that
our driver partners in many ways of the
face of the company
that's an area that we invest in and I
think more and more we're looking to
treat them as the true partners that
they are look at the external side of
the house there's a lot that you've been
doing internally and you mentioned that
another one of your tenants is going to
a place that actually can have an impact
and indeed uber has shown and
demonstrated that potential a former
high-ranking Google executive recently
said to The New Yorker that quote
everyone is terrified of uber you're
know is that person I'm not a mess in
the New Yorker so your competition is
gunning for you yes of course and one of
our beloved lecturers here Rob Siegel
often asks and popularize the following
question to visiting executives you have
one silver bullet to take out a
competitor who is it wow that is a tough
one a silver bullet to take out a
competitor you know might be a pink
competitor I'm not sure you know I
honestly think that right now the I
actually do very much believe that
companies that are to competitor focused
sometimes and many times stop caring
about what's important which is a
customer so if there's a silver bullet
for us it's actually really starting and
I think Ebor we have been to some extent
historically to guilty of competitors
and what they're doing and share etc we
are now really our operations teams and
our product teams and our technology
teams are working together in a way that
is customer obsessed and our customers
are the riders and the drivers and that
is you know if there's a silver bullet I
don't want to shoot it at the competitor
I actually want us to accelerate this
kind of new customer obsession as a
company because ultimately whether we
win or lose it ain't going to be about
what the competitors do it'sit's about
what we do you know we have we have a
global scope none of our competitors
have a global scope
we are multi
we've got a rides business that is
enormous and growing very quickly we
have an incredible new business growing
with eats we are getting two scooters
and bikes were getting into V tall's
vertical takeoff and landing product
we're getting into Freight etc the
definition of success we are taking out
so many competitors that I need a silver
shooting machine gun to take out my
competitors right so it's really we've
got to be focused internally in order to
win that's that's the real focus for us
lots of product lines and on top of that
you're planning on going public next
year yes how do you we talked about this
a little bit and specifically in the
context of uber how do you trade off
investing in growth R&D new products
with demonstrating predictable
profitability to shareholders um we're
not gonna have predictable profitability
and we'll say to our shareholders and
the shareholders can choose if they want
a predictably profitable company go buy
bank don't come to us I noticed when you
were describing your just I'd rather be
truthful I can't wait for your
shareholder letter hey I did have when I
was when I was at Expedia I I had a
still remember investor meeting with
with an investor and he talked for like
five minutes about being a long term
investor or a long term investor we're
gonna be an owner with he etc I'm like
so what's your average holding period
and he looked at me in like with those
deep eyes and he said nine months oh my
god so it's just you you've got there
are true long-term investors but just
like you can't be too competitive
focused just focus on the product state
who you are and and that comes with
limits and I think you will get
investors that you deserve and the
markets that we're going after are so
big and the position that we have is
unique and by the way we have lots of
tough tough competition that we will
find investors who hopefully agree with
us that that that that really the
long-term
what we're after and kind of what what I
like to talk to to my team about is we
I'm actually short-term impatient you
know I want the small ideas that take a
week and I'm long-term patient I'll take
the big ideas that take five years I
don't like the in-between and so if
there's a small idea get it to me get it
get it launched in a month get it
launched in two weeks I'll take that
I'll take the big long-term bets don't
come to me with in between one thing
when you were describing kind of the
product suite that you're most focused
about that I notice is that you did not
mention autonomous vehicles that's part
of the rideshare business I think I
think that with autonomous was different
about us yeah as it relates to other
companies out there is autonomous is not
a means to an end now autonomous
technology is going to be incredibly
exciting in terms of safety and
ultimately cost and providing this
services transportation of mobility
service to everyone everywhere
especially if you don't live in the
middle of the city
but I don't believe that autonomous
could be commercialized at the giant
scale that it has a potential to do so
without ride-sharing and I believe that
any ride share service that doesn't have
autonomous 15 to 20 years from now will
exist so to us autonomous and ride share
ultimately are going to be one in the
same and the Vantage that we have the
magic is that we are able to have them
under one roof and when we develop
autonomous we can develop it for a very
small use case which is for let's say 1%
by the way that one that very small use
case is going to be incredibly difficult
but 1% of routes than 2% of routes than
3% of routes the challenge is that we
have to take on and commercialization
are much much more simple than the
challenges that any autonomous only
player so for us autonomous and
rideshare they're ultimately going to be
one in the same for us
you think on the supply side eventually
uber might serve as a platform for
players right now who are saying they're
autonomous only like way mo oh very much
so
yeah we will
we'll welcome all comers and you'll see
that now for example we have a
integration with lime who is they have
bikes and scooters out there we already
I think they are alive in Oakland so
ultimately the vision that we see if
uber is we want to be that a to be
mobility and transportation platform for
people food and things and no one
company can provide all of the different
versions of transportation and mobility
we will look to integrate in all other
many many other third parties just like
Amazon has their own product and
third-party merchant product and we want
part of them ability to be hopefully
provided by cities the bus service metro
service etc we want to have all of that
available in uber so that if you say I
want to get to the city now what is the
best way for you to get to the city and
if the best way for you to is to take
Cal train you know we will tell you
exactly when it's coming we'll make
payment perfect and and and we will make
it predictable as far as your having
real-time data and hopefully you know at
some point we'll introduce surge pricing
and all the other cool stuff that we do
a lot to do yeah and I want to turn to
you now you my understanding is that
you've been commuting to the Bay Area
from Seattle the community has
officially stopped oh yes I have move
thank you very much that's fabulous news
internally at uber you are riding the
ship while simultaneously preparing for
this IPO you're also managing the
pressure of internal leaks and All Hands
meeting was recently just a day yes the
leaks had stopped until yesterday so but
you are working to repair trust with an
uber hmm how that's a lot of tension
yeah how do you maintain your sanity
who's your support system
I'd say my wife you know she's uh I I
say they they're they're they're two
elements one is when you come from a
family who's lost everything and then
rebuilt it it puts a perspective which
is
[Music]
I just kind of don't have a fear of loss
anymore because I know I'm gonna be okay
so the leak did it suck yeah but are
things getting better much better
and then when I get home and you know I
have dinner with my wife and my kids
it's all good
and the next day I'll do my best and and
you know what I know I always have with
me is my family and what I know I will
be true to is is really giving
everything I have to this opportunity
because it is an opportunity of a
lifetime
and I'm incredibly lucky to be in the
spot it's interesting because before you
came to over at Expedia we tried to
travel to India your visa got denied
yeah but apparently I wasn't a big deal
enough Oh BRR I got like of these like
that it was amazing and not only that
but you were meeting with Prime Minister
Modi yes and you know equally as CEO you
are making deals on an international
scale liaison with governments like the
UK in a world far after uber might we
one day see Secretary of State
Derrick Oscar shot oh I would be very
fearful for the country in that case I
you know I have joked that that my job
is half CEO half politician in this new
world but I I'm busy with all the
politics right here I don't think I want
to get into more politics than that one
last question before we let you go sure
all right we're gonna do a quick
lightning round oh okay I'm gonna give
you a prompt you can respond with a word
up to a sentence sounds good all right
fortnight or World of Warcraft Oh World
of Warcraft definitely um I actually
tried to have a date with my wife said
in World of Warcraft and I was this
gnome and you can put in these commands
to dance for her she was she was an elf
you know which compared to her you know
I am and know she didn't think it was
that cool but still
Steff Earlham run oh I gotta go with
Steph I mean I'm here Nine Inch Nails
are Radiohead Radiohead most definitely
I'm a big Radiohead fan your youngest of
three brothers as you said yes
Kavya Murad you're really trying you
start with booking.com
kicking our ass and then take a team you
know the proper answer of the young
brother is Dhara I'm the youngest ooh I
can relate um Pike Place Market or Ferry
Building marketplace
I gotta go with Pike Place for now gotta
love Seattle that's you know it's in the
skin profits our growth girls iPhone our
Android iPhone lifts our taxi cabs I
will walk before
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]